you wrote that at the age of 13 you were
first exposed to plane geometry
and was wander struck by the power and
elegance of formal proofs
are there problems proofs properties
ideas in plain geometry that
from that time that you remember being
mesmerized by or just
enjoying to go through to prove
various aspects so michael rabin told me
this story
about an experience he had when he was a
young student
who was ex tossed out of his classroom
for bad behavior and was wandering
through the corridors of his school
and came upon two older students who
were
studying the problem of finding the
shortest distance between two
non-overlapping circles
and michael thought about it and said
you take the straight line between the
two centers
and the segment between the two circles
is the shortest
because a straight line is the shortest
distance between the two centers
in any other line connecting the circles
would be
on a on a longer line and i thought
and he thought and i agreed that this
was just
elegant the pure reasoning could come up
with
such a result certainly the the shortest
distance from the two centers of the
circles
is a straight line could you once again
say
what's the next step in that proof well
any
any segment joining the the two
circles uh if you
extend it by taking the radius on each
side
you get a segment with a path with three
edges which connects the two centers
and this has to be at least as long as
the shortest path which is the straight
line the straight line
yeah wow yeah that is that's quite
quite simple so what what is it about
that elegance that
you just find uh compelling well just
that you could
establish a uh a fact
about geometry beyond dispute by pure
reasoning
i i also enjoy the challenge of
solving puzzles in plain geometry it was
much more fun
than the earlier mathematics courses
which were mostly about
arithmetic operations and manipulating
them
was was there something about geometry
itself the slightly visual component of
it
yes absolutely although i lacked
three-dimensional vision i wasn't very
good at
three-dimensional vision i mean being
able to visualize three-dimensional
objects
three-dimensional objects or or
surfaces hyper planes and so on um
so so there there i didn't have an
intuition
but
for example the fact that the sum of the
angles of a triangle is 180 degrees
uh is is proved
convincingly um and
it comes as a surprise that that can be
done
why is that surprising the the
well it is a surprising uh is a
surprising idea
i suppose uh why does that prove
difficult it's not
that's the point it's so easy and yet
it's so convincing
do you remember what is the proof that
it's um
as up to 180 uh you you
start at a corner and draw
a line um
parallel to the opposite side
and that line sort of trisects the angle
between the other two sides
and uh you you get a
uh a half plane which has to add up to
180 degrees
and it consists and the angles by
by the equality of alternate
angles what's it called um
you you you get a correspondence between
the angles
created by the side along the side of
the
triangle and the three angles of the
triangle
has geometry had an impact on when you
look into the future of
your work with combinatorial algorithms
has it had some kind of
impact in terms of yeah being able
the puzzles the visual aspects that were
first so compelling to you
not euclidean geometry particularly
i think uh
i use tools like linear programming and
integer programming a lot and
but those require
high dimensional visualization and so i
tend to go by the
algebraic um right the
you you go by the algebra the linear
algebra and not by the
visualization well the interpretation in
terms of
for example finding the highest point on
a polyhedron
as in linear programming
is motivating um but again
it i don't have the high dimensional
intuition
that would particularly inform me so i
sort of deep lean on the algebra
you